[Music]
all right you guys are we're gonna do a
little role play right now no michael
get your head out of the gutter
i like role play okay
i just want to put that out there i like
what you make your lips this is what i
do for a living
uh not that kind of role play michael uh
we're gonna do a role play where you
imagine that you are late to a flight
i like where this is going i'm really
upset i'm upset dude yeah i'm freaking
out at a south florida airport oh no
who's gonna suck my dick bro i'm already
in the back room getting scanned by the
scene now
i've already i've already i'm getting
i'm getting cheap you're getting an anal
probe from the seat
bomb swipe random check right here
they're putting a a bomb robot inside of
your body up your rectum it's over for
me robots to the robot okay got it why
does the robot have to be shaped like
this
i want to let everyone know i'm not
gonna make the flight i'm not making the
flight we'll see you in the next one you
know perfectly put touch thank you i'll
see everyone in guantanamo i can see it
too i can picture it okay
you're late you're you want to get on
this plane so super badly how do you
stop the flight
how do i stop the fight i mean that's
your intent your character's intent
you're an actor you're currently
intelligent you know what i'm gonna do
you wish to stop the fight what are you
gonna do there's someone on a with a
bomb on the flight this is i wanna if i
my only goal is to stop the flight my
eyes are still closed i don't know why i
was still
i liked that one
mine were closed until i ran out of
answers i was like are there any answers
around here if there was no consequences
the easiest the easiest way to stop the
flight is one of you just yell i'm a
terrorist
well done unfortunately there are
consequences ah
then i'd
so sure you stop the flight or someone
on the flight stop your character wishes
to stop the flight because we're trying
to get on you're not on yet we're trying
to get on
there's someone on this flight no in
your a mind's eye you believe that if
you can just convince everyone not to
start flying yet that you'll get on the
plane eventually yeah so you tell them
that specific airplane has a bomb on it
and i need to point out who that's
correct and then you call it you don't
get to get on the flight they're going
to have me go on there so i can point
them out but you have to remember this
person is in florida
or what if you tell the the the person
at the kiosk
someone stole my kid and they're inside
you guys are all smarter than this
person so this person
um
what the [ __ ] did this guy do this is
dumber than saying that you're a
terrorist it is wow
oh well it's basically the same thing
but
instead of saying there is a bomb on
this plane i own a plane
[Laughter]
i hold the plane on american airlines
john america
she stated that there's a bomb in her
checked-in luggage that was aboard the
plane in order to delay the planes
taking off so she could get she could
get on and go
[ __ ] at you
dude i love i love how
i'm assuming this person was white
i don't know she's 46 years old
and her name is karen johnson
she's actually from chicago but she was
on a plane at south florida airport
after missing her play what airline was
she flying uh frontier they don't say
she's either a white senior citizen or a
colombian drug lord love it
those i think are both accurate guesses
damn
well because it's south florida right
those are the only two that exist here's
my take on this only a white lady would
be like i'm a terrorist just kidding all
this will be fine
honey i know what happens
imagine her being like turning around be
like i've got this ladies
like if she's like traveling with her
girlfriend yeah she's like she's awake
has anyone seen tech
wilson i know i know a guy will
sacrifice him
this fella over here
wait he needs one of those
tests do you really get stopped there
all the [ __ ] time how like what's the
ratio still oh yeah i would say at least
75 of the time they'll be like random
check it's not like anything crazy
egregious but the fact that you do a
random check it's random it's random
they'll always do the bomb swipe where
they take that like little sticky note
that's like this thin it's like one inch
thin and they like swipe your hands yeah
yeah and then they stick it in my butt
bomb residue like bomb residue and then
the other thing i always love this is
that
i pre-check i have clear i have all of
it i take my computer out and they're
like you got you have a nintendo in
there the nintendo like
you mean a switch and i'm like yeah
they're like take take it out now i'm
like here i am so they know what it is
they know what it is and they think this
dude is he's going to blow up his switch
which which makes me feel like these
guys have never tried to buy a [ __ ]
switch not during covent because they're
impossible again
why would i blow up my space
it's
[Laughter]
when i came back from chicago yeah there
was an air marshal flying right next to
me first time this is how do you know he
was open about it what yeah like he was
over he had a badge what the [ __ ] yeah
he's like
they just give you these white gangs
so he he sat right next to me he sat
right next to me but we were we were we
were in aisle seats
and
like one hour into the flight
he pulls out a [ __ ] switch and i'm
like this [ __ ] i wonder if they
bomb swiped this [ __ ] switch
because they did to me and then we
played mario kart for another
player yes of course i'm local sounds
like these [ __ ] don't know
that's something any of you imagine if i
was actually a terrorist and he was at
like an air market did you beat him
irony of that situation would have been
insane he has so much no i dominated he
he tried to be good but if i'm him i'm
like hey take a dab in this next race
or you're not going home
hey you picked dollars or you drive
that's just slow
dude i still get stopped airport once in
a while if i fly to new york someone
will recognize me but it's it's like
really awkward because it'll be someone
who was i mean i don't know how old
these tsa agents are but it's like
someone who had to be around 1816 while
like stitchers was on because they
recognized me
like oh my oh my god your
your your and sometimes they won't
finish their sentence just to see if
they remember my name yeah because they
recognize they'll like recognize you but
they you're like
you're
you're and then they'll have to like get
it from my boarding back
the amount of times
the amount of times i've been called
seth green
is actually wild second grade really
they know my name is s green but they
can't figure it out and so seth green's
the most famous s green and so they're
just like
seth green and i'm like i know you don't
know who i am
but i will say
there was a stint when i went to new
york and it was in winter so i just was
getting ramen just like all these hole
in the walls and i got recognized by
almost every host from jk news what no
way
yeah they were like you're you're that
you're the indian guy on jk
and i'm like you're living i'm like
that's me
you're the team
oh [ __ ] what happened there's a huge
amount of people who work at airports
who watch jk it's actually crazy the
amount of jk love i get at airport a lot
of tsa be like yo jk
well here is my my love letter to the
tsa please stop
bomb swiping me and my my random uh i'm
on tv come on i'm not even blind i did
have one security lady go oh he doesn't
need to be checked he's on tv and i was
like really that's all that's it that's
all it takes
oj was on tv yeah
that's so crazy so yeah it worked uh she
definitely stopped the plane but she was
not allowed to get on the plane
unfortunately and she was charged
yeah
she was arrested and charged on the
floor they're on the conveyor belt
luggage thing dude if i was on that
plane and it got stopped i'd be [ __ ]
i hope they did [ __ ] like drop her
everybody should do that that scene out
of airplane where they'll slap the chick
in the face they should all get a line
to do that every single person didn't
get to go where they were going because
of this chick so the flight was delayed
because it was fort lauderdale
hollywood international and they have to
check right they have to check
everything they have to so the the plane
gets rerouted
passengers get evacuated plane gets
searched obviously no explosives are
found i think you should set her on fire
have you heard of the casino black book
list
so when you get on the it's a book of
people who cannot go to the casino or um
of all of them yeah me and dana white
dude on the same [ __ ] list so if
you're a car counter if you're a cheater
if you're a thief or whatever and once
you get on that list
all of them share the same one oh all of
them dude all of them so you could be at
the ces palace you could be at [ __ ] i
don't know like another casino out of
new york or whatever they all share the
same list so once you become
a part of that you can't gamble at any
casinos because all the security people
share the same one and you know how they
have crazy technology when you walk in
and like the [ __ ] cameras can catch
you and [ __ ] like an airplane take your
mask down they should do that
for uh like flight like people that'd be
so sick yeah yeah it's like you're an
[ __ ] you can't fly yeah you start
[ __ ] on one plane you get out of here
that's it like this lady who [ __ ]
called a bomb threat on and like ruined
it for everybody else i think she should
be on this note she shouldn't be able to
fly go on a train or rent a car she
should be able to own it
yeah yeah yeah yeah the punishment is
only greyhound oh my god
and it's for work i don't care you
should show the [ __ ] rent a horse there
there is
i think i read something about a
congresswoman from alaska who
was like auntie mask and then alaska
banned her because she didn't want to
wear a mask but like now she has no way
to like get to the government building
which i think she got kicked out of the
government i heard something they were
like take a boat
you can
take a boat you could probably take a
boat to the alaskan capital i don't know
i don't know what is it anchorage the
anchorage
is that the capital
that feels like a different country very
hot alaska and hawaii two different
countries connected to canadian
[Music]
you